aars throw off Jets of particles that
are so bright they outshine all the
stars in their galaxies so our sun would
essentially turn into a candle in the
middle of a very bright Spotlight the
illumination from aazar along with all
the radiation it throws off would mess
with Earth's
atmosphere the light is enough to
energize particles that make up the
atmosphere and free them from Earth's
gravity our atmosphere would be
destroyed and and we really need our
atmosphere it's our protective layer
that keeps things in order and regulates
the temperature without it the oceans
would dry up Arctic Ice would turn into
water vapor and everything would get
much much
hotter in addition to it being
blindingly bright we would have no safe
air to Breathe No plants to eat or feed
animals and there would be no water to
drink life on Earth would be a wrof